[Musique]
ce
magasin
[Musique]
tu m'as sauvé la ville
pourquoi ce que j'ai vu dans ton regard
sens de l'honneur
j'ai une dette de sang envers toi
depuis 600 ans notre clan maintient la
paix au japon
aux côtés de nos alliés
les jo
rejoignant
j'ai besoin de guerriers comme toi pour
lutter contre encore 1 c'est quoi que
moi la plus grande organisation
terroriste au monde
ils vont déclencher une guerre
désolé c'est pas mon combat alors
pourquoi tu es ici
[Musique]
on a tué mon père quand j'étais gamin je
n'ai pas de maison
je me fais appeler ce n'est qu'avec ça
parce que je n'ai jamais eu de chance je
ne peux pas te donner un an ni à passer
mais je veux donner
un sens à ta vie
[Musique]
je continue de croire que c'est une
erreur tu penses que je mettrais ce que
en danger
cobra aura ta peau
[Musique]
je sens que j'ai apprécié sommes un
petit peu
tu l'as pas vu venir celui là
[Musique]
vidéo quel score
ciné crise
au cinéma le 18 août